I've lived
38 going on 39 years on this Earth and
it wasn't until this year where I found
I think my favorite go-to daily coffee
like yeah I like all the crazy like
horata Lattes or pumpkin spice lattes
like that like dessert in a cup drinks
but like my go-to daily it was really
basic it was just like a regular vanilla
latte or regular latte until I was put
on Mexican sty coffee coffe de Oya and
um it's so good cuz it's like honey and
it's cinnamon and it gives me like this
um that spice flavor that I like with
pumpkin spice without it feeling too
much like a dessert like it feels like
it's made in the coffee rather than
something that's meant to be like
calorie dense so Gio's mom is so nice
and she got me my own like instant
coffee OA and I've been drinking this um
with honey and it's so good I don't put
creamer cuz you know you guys know I'm
on a bodybuilding prep so I can't have
too many calories but I was missing this
and what balances out the cinnamon
that's in here is something sweet and
I'm like oh what can I do what can I do
and I always forget I have the best wife
in the world and she has all kinds of
stuff so I found some sugar-free French
vanilla so I'm going to mix it together
and see how it tastes let's put in
here and if you don't have one of these
you should this is a instant hot water
the water is constantly at
28° so it's very convenient for any hot
drinks
or um instant noodles or any or oatmeal
like you don't have to boil water or
anything it's instant look just hit
unlock so it's safe hit dispence boom
instant hot
water all right moment of truth I'm
usually not a big fan of AR artificial
sweetener the only things I've grown
accustomed to with the artificial
sweeteners is like pre-work out protein
energy
drinks um like Diet pepper like pretty
much all the like Fitness diety stuff so
when it's like a warm drink and it has
that artificial sweetener still kind of
throws me off but desperate times calls
for desperate measures you know what I'm
saying M French vanilla that actually
smells very very good oh no don't tell
me the Cap's broken no it is I have to
fix it like tape so I have to just
carefully pour it in like
this all
right going to mix it
in little by little so you don't get
that crazy syrupy
flavor let's
see
[Applause]
m not bad needs a little bit more oh
there goes the
aftertaste by the way did I ever share
with you guys where I got these mugs
that Happ all right so before everything
got spilled what I was trying to show
you guys about this mug is actually uh I
don't know if I share this mug with you
guys but this is my favorite mug in the
whole world we have I think four of them
maybe let's see yeah we got yeah we got
maybe three
no I think we have four maybe I broke
one of them but we actually got them at
a thrift store for pretty cheap but I
what I really liked about it I believe
it's like that um super thick insulated
kind cuz any drink you put in here it
stays super hot or super cold and it's
like this German which I'm kind of
scared about the dates but I figured
it's I don't see any um symmetrical
logos on there you know what I'm talking
about so it doesn't seem like it's not
safe so it just it's just a really cool
like vintage mug and it keeps the coffee
nice and hot but the verdict is I still
don't like artificial sweeteners in my
coffee tastes kind of
weird so I got these C no I don't even
know what these are oh that's like a
almond pastry you see that yeah how come
how come you don't trust it mister he's
not impr Mama made that it took like 9
hours you know that yeah they're almond
croissants it doesn't look appetizing I
got to I got
uh so the way they were oh if it's on
the picture oh cuz you got to toast it
again yeah yeah look so they come like
really tiny and you have to let them sit
in room temperature for 9 hours then it
Rose to this but then by the time it was
9 hours he was already going to bed so
then um yeah if it look like that
picture it will look good but put it in
the fridge yeah if it look like that no
that looks to sit in room temperature
for 9 hours over now you will be
astonished about how it grows can I just
put it in there like even if it's cold
or should I leave it
room you can put in there you sure yeah
cuz now I did the room tempting and it
went oh just to put it in the oven after
room temp I don't know it didn't really
specify just put in there it's fine I
buy apple turnovers and I put in the
fridge and I put the post oven all the
time and it tastes just
fine let's see how it tastes well
actually I I don't get to see how it
tastes yeah you don't act like you don't
can I get a bite can I get a bite can I
get a bite can I get a
bite
all right today is a special day why cuz
we got a DJ in the
house do that that sound uh our pool is
getting plastered super stoked we have
everyone here in the back doing their
thingy thing and we got a truck over
here yeah look at that Contraption so
that's not even part of our house that's
just like the mid Alleyway but I think
they figured out that's probably the
smartest way so they bought the big old
truck dumping all that material whatever
that material is they could have totally
driven it in here right oh they're
putting blue did you see that blue
that's the color of the the what is it
called gun night or whatever Knight or
no plaster I don't know but they're
don't look at me like I know what the
hell well they're putting like blue
powder in there so I think that's
probably the flaky flakes I love that
they have a pole there already cuz
that's probably all they need the pole
for what pole the pole that he's where
the trash is going to keep it from
flying
see it oh yeah where he stuffs it yeah
so yeah he's putting it in there that
tube goes through that gate into the
backyard all handson deck there's like
20 people back here oh and that guy is
blowing the guy with the cow the cowboy
hat is
blowing we got the everything taped up
got the jacuzzi got the
Koozies and then people
prepping what does that mean does that
mean our pool is swimmable in like a
week maybe even less what who's growling
is that your Bo yeah mean meanwhile we
got Cooper the security anytime he
doesn't recognize anybody he starts
growling right there H he's L right
there yeah but what's so cute is he's so
little that he doesn't know that he's
little and then he looks cute and not
scary
yet another
that that guy whoa you just
flipped it nice
and oh there it
is
[Applause]
so how do they build a pool taica I just
went outside yeah and what did you see I
saw them build it yeah what's the
process what is that process is like a
step by step how do they do it did you
see them like yeah first they dig and
then and then they just put cement in
there and then they put the C in it but
and then I was running and H what are
they doing now spraying something was
like running in the boink boink I didn't
see anybody boink in their head yeah I
was running to his and I
think who boed are you sure that's a
different story I friend no it's for
real oh okay had a bump right here oh a
long time ago yeah yeah yeah and then
what do they do now they're spraying and
what do they have to do after they spray
it they smooth it smooth it out they
make it dry and then they put swim swim
are you excited to be able to swim soon
don't by myself time Flor no all of us
are going to swim together mhm should we
ask your cousins to come again oh yeah
remember the I remember the last time
when it was my birthday they came and I
was swimming I think I was Swimming by
myself without anybody holding me really
by
yourself I met I did you have a floaty
on no cuz I don't think you know how to
swim yet I I us I remember when I was a
little guy your little guy yeah I turned
backwards and then I turned every in a
circle and I didn't anybody holding me
oh like here there we do have a a Splash
Zone so it's going to be safe there is a
whole middle part of the pool where you
don't even need a floaty pretty cool huh
cuz we have the water like maybe just
right there right under your
nose well if you put your nose in the
water then you can't breathe but if it's
like right there right here I'm going to
die aha so it does look gold golden
brown now yep what's the ver oh and a
book oh yeah baby oh this is a me time
right there as much as I could get it in
I'm going to get it in but yeah I made
myself some JY matcha I actually prefer
matcha over coffee yes I always prefer
Macho over coffee but it just depends on
the day um if I'm like really exhausted
and I just need something to just get me
going immediately then it's coffee and I
always regret it honestly I always
regret drinking coffee cuz one the shits
two I get jittery three the crash is the
freaking worst and I'm not the biggest
fan of the coffee flavor unless it's
like super premium quality and usually
if I need coffee it's because I need it
now so I'm usually making it myself and
it's not the best um but I do prefer
matcha because it's just a cleaner
caffeine source for me and it's a
gradual pickup but it's a constant
pickup I don't get the crash I don't get
the Jitters um and then I always like
I'm like I'll look at the time and I'm
like usually around this time I'm
supposed to supposed to crash cuz I'll
be used to coffeee uh and then I'm like
oh right I had watch yet and I'm still
doing good there's no you know what the
scientific reason
is um no but I have a feeling you're
going tell
me because the um matcha has uh innate
fenine in it so naturally occurring in
the leaf and the theanine regulates how
fast your body absorbs caffeine we have
theanine in our pre-workout B Brigade
pre-workout yeah so that that's that's
also why our pre-workout doesn't have a
crash it doesn't have a crash cuz it
modulates it so it lets you slowly
receive it and then slowly go away
versus like boom night and day yeah yeah
yeah so I do this is my preferred source
of caffeine so today you it's your day
for taica so you like got him ready made
him breakfast and I'm like oh I get to
chill oh the DJ's back you're spraying
that means it's spraying again oh [__]
they're so fast yeah so got these from
uh treer Joe's I love an almond
croissant so oh I knew it was going to
have that sound oh okay okay okay I
haven't had any food that had that sound
like 3
months oh my dear
Lord that sounded so
good is it good shut the [__] up [__]
shut the [__] up
[__] he so good shut the [__] up you
[__] [__] hold on I got to I got to
gram this real quick what the [__] it is
so good I'm going to say 10 out of 10
would recommend yep damn can I have a
bite hold on I knew
it peekaboo what up cutie oh you got the
yummy brownies yeah he wants to eat that
in the car while we go get groceries so
my coach throughout this whole
bodybuilding prep has prescribed me
12,000 steps a day because I keep doing
a have can I have a bite I'm
self-prescribing 15,000 so this is oh
actually it's 16,000 now every day I hit
16,000 steps just cuz I know I'm going
to have these little bites but it's so
worth it and it keeps my
sanity I'm eat the side cuz that's where
the filling
at that's a big ass bite you ate more
than half
no 10 out of 10 right isn't it
delicious get it from Trader Joe's this
is so worth it monkey you're going to
love it really really really really
really good fine it's a little bit warm
though okay be careful it's a little bit
warm it's crunchy no don't smash it here
I'm not trying to smash it Che
it did you get any the feeling cuz the
inside is what the yummy yeah that's
that's where the sweet stuff yeah get
the side you
think not delicious your eyes don't roll
back it's just all right well probably
because he gets to eat that kind of
stuff every single day do you like it I
like what what you just the croissant
no I like I want to chocol inside well
look at that Mama when you got stuff
like that every day it's kind of hard to
all right all right I even write my name
on it oh yeah no one's going to take it
it's yours so if I lost I can if I lose
it I can eat it did you brush your teeth
not in the morning yet so we just got
back from walking the dogs and it looks
like they stopped putting the plaster
and I think now they're just going to
smooth everything out but just looking
at it from here I don't know if it's
finalized but if it is it's going to
look so beautiful cuz I see like very
subtle hints of like baby blue in it
yeah so now imagine once the water's in
there ooh the whole water going just be
baby blue it's going be so like Serene
yes look might even look like that guy's
shirt
yeah maybe that's why he wore that shirt
to let you know to give me a hint like
it's going to look like me baby girl
when you swim think of me
Rodrigo what what's his name
it is crazy how fast they're moving we
barely walk the dogs for like 30 minutes
and look how smooth that is
already
wow what do you wish you were allergic
to all the vegetabl all the vegetables
why and then I said iic to junk food and
and then I said iic to one to two
vegetables you know Papa wishes he was
allergic to junk food cuz then Papa
would never be fat but Papa loves junk
food so much yeah I like you look you
look you look crazy when you were fat do
you like Papa now or he's more buff or
you like when Papa's fat I like when
Papa's fat you like when Papa's fat are
you kidding me yeah you look funny he
say I look funny when I'm fat are you
fasinating me I'm going to cancel you
dude I'm going cancel you bro what's
that you bet you better you you about to
find out you about to find out player so
today I'm heading to LA to film JK news
and every time I'm at JK news it is
Temptation Galore there's snacks
everywhere they order always order the
bombest food during lunch after we film
people are like oh you guys want to go
out and eat so to avoid that I'm going
to try to pack my own food so I don't
make anything any stupid decisions so I
found a pretty tasty way to still fit my
diet if I get uh chicken tenders AKA
chicken breast which is like 20 g of
protein with less than 1 gr of fat if I
stir fry these with uh marinara it's
actually pretty good and it doesn't
taste like diet food so I'm getting 3
lbs cuz I eat one pound of chicken each
time so I have one for lunch today one
for lunch on Thursday one for lunch on
Friday so I really got to prepare so I
can resist the temptation and why are
you looking at me with those funny eyes
oh because I heard the kid joke of like
marinara but it's like what's the DJ
like I don't know what's it's like the
pizza DJ's name or
something I forgot I forgot what it is I
know the punch mama with the dad jokes
huh Can you put this in
there isn't that crazy one lb is one
meal for me that's how much protein I
have to hit that is crazy I I eat like 2
to three lounds of meat every day right
now that's that's pretty crazy huh yeah
and you're still complaining you're
hungry it's not enough
food so it's just our bittersweet
chocolate milk milk and whipped cream
that's it thank you you're welcome it's
a lucky day Mister let me try let me try
are they giving out samples is that what
that is ooh if it is a sample I'm going
try oh thank you I love you you know
that I love you more today than anytime
ever else the try is good you didn't
even try it yet how do you know I know
hot choc Oh my
Jesus I thought you knew what hot
chocolate tastes like how did you burn
yourself is that good or what cuz it's
hot hot chocolate hot chocolate hot hot
hot hot wonder where you get you burn
how did you burn your mouth then if you
there a resemblance uncanny resemblance
between the attitude look what I found
sugarfree red raspberry preserves only
calories and it probably has sucros yes
so it's always a gamble because anything
with like that sugar-free usually has an
artificial sweetener and sometimes they
know how to do a good job of hiding it
sometimes they don't but everything
right now is worth a try cuz I'm
dying cuz unless it tastes like that
where it's true chocolate true true
dessert it's melted it's hot milk
chocolate yeah it's delicious cha isot
so there's this keto bread that's
actually really really good um good as
in it's good for on a diet not like it's
extremely delicious but look One Bun is
only 16 G of car carbs so right now for
someone like me I have about 60 G of
carbs total in a day which means like a
a really small cup of oatmeal is already
30 so that's half then if I can have
something like this that means I can
have two buns if I don't get something
like this I can only have one bun cuz
usually like one bread is already like
10 to 15 gam of carbs so I love this
that it's so low in carbs cuz um I get
to make like two burgers which in my
brain feels like more filling you know a
lot of it's psychological too but yeah
I'm getting these bad boys I finished it
so this is how I make my easy peasy
chicken get chicken breast right look at
that 26 g of protein under 1 G of fat so
you can have two servings of that or I'm
going to eat a whole pound so that's 100
g of protein with like 2 G of fat which
is awesome and then I buy this specific
burilla marinara sauce this one's
roasted garlic look at this 0.5 G of fat
again only 50 calories you can use a
whole half cup so this is like almost
nothing still it's almost negligible
depending on how low your calories are
where I'm at now I have to plug every
single thing in um because like whether
or not I plug it in and track it my
weight will fluctuate the next day cuz
I'm I'm like Teeter tottering right
there so it's really simple I'm just
going to Salt and Pepper season probably
do some little Cajun pour it on there
and then this is 3 lb which is 3
meals when I'm fruit prepping I like to
keep things as simple as possible cuz
it's all about convenience I'm making
Mass quantity no matter how good you
make it taste it's not going to taste
like a cheat meal anyways so I'm just
going to even just season it in these
little containers it comes with so that
I don't have to have like a ton of
dishes to do so I just start out with
something simple like garlic salt
and then depending on how much meat is
in each kind of season accordingly some
pepper what I realized is pepper on
chicken tastes really good you know like
um one key to like meal
prepping is you want the food to taste
as good for as long as possible cuz
sometimes if you're meal prepping you
might not you might have this food last
like 3 4 5 days and having a a generous
amount of pepper it actually makes the
chicken taste fresh still um for up to
like 3 or 4 days like that chickening
taste doesn't come out so right here I
have a little bit of slap Mama seasoning
just to give it a little kick a little
bit more like Flavor in it mix it up in
here mix it up in here oh yeah you have
the there's like a weird um tampon in
there that soaks up everything but mix
it up and that's
it
then I just take these bad boys and just
dump it dump one in
there dump one in
here and then dump one in
here then what I'm looking for is right
when it gets to like a slight golden
brown I don't want to overcook it and
make chicken breast dry cuz it's very
easy once it gets to like a slight
golden brown is when I throw in the
marinara and then I just let it simmer
see move it around and since I was only
able to season one side I might just
season the other side just a little bit
too and with the burger patties I got
these keto ones I mean uh Burger buns
sorry I'm low on calories I have ate
nothing today so far besides that coffee
that you guys saw I already prepped my
burger
patties like I said it's all about
avoiding Temptation so already prepped
my burger patties uh this is
964 and I'm going to pack some of this
Trader Joe low calorie organic ketchup
see it's only 20 calories per
tablespoon um pop these in here probably
make little double deckers so per One
Bun I'll have two slices of
meat and this will be like literally
just this and just the chicken will be
my meals for the next 2 days and I think
that might allow me maybe even one or
200 calories of Wier room so that could
be like a rice cake
or um something slightly to munch on
like pretzels or something but yeah it's
going to be rough but the more I can
have my meals mapped out and thought of
ahead of time the more piece of mine I
have and the more piece of mind I have
the less Munchies you have cuz you can
stick to plan you know
two more three more weeks we got this so
now that these bad boys are kind of like
medium rare-ish I don't want to overcook
them it's time to pour the tomato sauce
on it cuz I'm going to let it simmer
here for like a
good I would say
maybe like 5
minutes and then that should be fully
cooked probably put another another jar
in it and Bam
that's it I had it on a a medium low
simmer for 3
minutes that's pretty much
done I'll keep it here what's cool about
stuff with marinades and sauces is the
longer you wait the more of the flavor
goes into the meat especially when it's
something tough like chicken so I'm just
going to let this sit here once it cools
down put it in tupperware then I'll pack
my chicken meals my beef
meals and I'll be ready to get on the
road still got a couple more things I
have to do in terms of work and then uh
then I'm already packed so I hate
packing day of so one other trick that I
like to do since I travel so much now is
I always pack the day before I hate
doing things last minute cuz that's how
you miss things that's how you're a mess
like you always see people like showing
up at the airport with stuff falling on
of their backpacks and their cars and
stuff I don't want to be that guy CU
things could happen right like if you
already
getting to the airport in a mess what if
an emergency happens at the airport you
know like things happen what if there's
a bomb threat or there's an active
shooter or like you you're not 100%
there so everywhere I go I like try to
be like 100% there I don't want to show
up at a place 75% and then something
crazy happens you know so my stuff's
already packed that's my ghee um I've
dedicated myself to doing Jiu-Jitsu two
times a week right now so even if that
means they could all be at my home gym
in La that be I mean uh Vegas that' be
awesome but if not I stop by lion harw
Nick trains and I get in some rolles
there I've even stopped by henzo Gracie
in East LA and that was really cool just
I don't want to make traveling an excuse
I don't want to make not being familiar
with the gym an excuse I'm Bri Mye I'm
doing two times a week not negotiable
that's it so I already have that packed
and ready to go as well the backyard is
looking
nice little by little look at that I
think they're
done that's it
is it really just ready for water
now that looks clean or do they need to
put another layer well the truck's gone
so I don't think they need to put
another layer but I guess now they just
fill it up with
water but this looks clean so we chose
the um is it called pebbletech I think
that's the layer between so it goes like
concrete then plaster then I think
Pebble Tech and then you fill up with
water and we chose one that's going to
give a nice like hint light blue so it
looks very Mediterranean so you'll see
everything's like gray white and then
light blue and it's going to be plants
all up there so it'll be all
green it's turning out really
good I'm so glad that uh they're able to
complete that step today before I leave
so that when I come back hopefully
there's water in it that' be crazy ooh
our hot tub I haven't had one of these
bad boys in a long
time I am so
excited so this is what I'm packing in
terms of my meal preps I got my three
meals worth of chicken right here there
three lbs of chicken got all the
patties got the bread low
calorie um ketchup I usually wouldn't
travel with condiments I just don't know
if I have time to stop by Trader Joe's
cuz once I get to La it's like busy busy
busy busy so I just want to be as
prepared as possible I also found this
thing this is like a ranch style mint
mix seasoning that has 0 g of fat 0 g of
carbs so I just wanted to taste I'll
probably sprinkle some of this on the
chicken see if it tastes good or maybe
even on the patties but putting um
little cooler in there putting this here
it perfect doesn't fit like that so I
probably got to put this
down yep that works and then if that
should still be able to close right oh
no I'm going to have to put the patties
in a different container and then I'll
put the Buns right here like that and uh
ready to go you going to miss me
Cooper I don't think so are you going to
miss me monkey man yeah C the throw up
on he threw up yeah looks like a better
yeah we have to clean up the bile over
there yes are you going to miss me do
you miss me when I go to
laig
C okay and that's it got got my luggage
my
food are you really going to miss me
mister you big Cy you promise cuz you
know I always miss you so
much where you going hey papa can't
leave the door you big Cy oh you lock it
uh-oh that means Papa really can't go
you big Cy guy I
know it always makes me miss him so much
and hurts to leave too it like this I
can open it like
this but yeah thank you guys for
watching me get ready to leave to LA on
my bodybuilding prep so it is one extra
layer it is one extra you take my food
it is one extra layer to have to not
just think about your luggage and also
my duffel bag to get my gym duffel bag
out but also my my commitments like
Jiu-Jitsu and my luggage now I have to
think about my about to do all that um
so it's all going to be worth it though
see you guys in the next
Vlog he keeps taking all my stuff
cutie where you taking all my stuff you
you B